another teen angst movie it is a genre
now it's a genre teen angst
holy-shit divergent so divergent is a
movie for Twilight fans who claim
they're not Twilight fans but they're
actually Twilight fans so they jumped on
the Hunger Games train now they're
looking for something new because
they're bored with that [ __ ] now now we
have divergent and divergent takes place
in the future where everyone sorted into
different groups
everyone has their role to play for
society you sit in this chair and this
electronic sorting hat from Harry Potter
tells you whether or not you're going
into Gryffindor Hufflepuff Ravenclaw
Slytherin and one other one because
there's five groups in here but Harry
Potter only has four but some people
don't fit in any group in there are
menace to society if you're a divergent
does what those people are called they
take you in the back of a shed or
something shoot you shailene woodley in
this movies one of these people she's
like I'm gonna go into the hardcore
group they're ultimately the police yeah
and the future we leave the safety of
society in the hands of teenagers yeah
we're [ __ ] and now we have our movie
and there were things I actually liked
about the movie the movie's not perfect
or anything but [ __ ] in the movie that
doesn't make sense for sure there's a
romance of course the movie ultimately
revolves around heard being trained and
I like seeing her getting trained I like
seeing her going from this you know
frumpy normal chick is kind of nice just
like I guess I'll do the hard core
course because they're exciting then she
gets all hot it out she's efficient the
coolest part about it is that she's
efficient factor she gets more
attractive it's a little bonus but I'm
just saying I like seeing her become
badass better than that you actually buy
the fact that she does become badass
she's one of those people she's normal
at first but she has guts
we need guts if you saw my Ender's Game
Review ultimately I was like I like the
movie because I like seeing him train
because I like boot camp [ __ ] and space
in the future and stuff and that's
ultimately what this movie is for the
majority of it so I enjoyed that [ __ ]
Kate Winslet's in the movie Kate wins I
feel like she was shoehorned into this
movie to bring some level of credibility
like she does artsy movies put her in
divergent the parents at the Hunger
Games fans will actually go to this
movie if she's in it she was good the
movie I mean you buy the fact that she's
a [ __ ] she's supposed to know she's a
[ __ ] and right when you see her you're
like yeah she's a [ __ ] she's a
corporate [ __ ] she is and she plays
her part well and in the last section of
this movie the climax of the movie where
the shit's going down there's actually a
couple of touching scenes where you're
like oh my god movie wanted to be sad it
was actually sad and yes some things in
the movie don't make sense at all I
blame the source material I imagine it's
this way in the book
it's in the movie so I got a touch on it
we're talking these are hard times the
divergent people are being hunted they
they are being eliminated everyone who
is one knows that they're gonna be dead
soon I gotta hide it I gotta hide it
deep down try to blend in so this one
person who is a divergent has a tattoo
on his body clearly saying hey I'm one
of those people why would you do that
[ __ ] that is like in Berlin during the
Holocaust getting a big tattoo on your
chest of your family gathered around in
Hanukah it's not good to have don't do
that while it's going down do it after
it's over and no one pushes the envelope
example they have these darts that feel
like real bullets people get shot with
them they like ah [ __ ] [ __ ] why are you
you [ __ ] guess that's what I would say
if I got shot by something that felt
like a bullet in that tone to proudly my
biggest gripe with movies like this is
like it's a pg-13 movie let the people
actually be human and curse once in a
while no one's gonna be like ah man so I
got shailene woodley was good in the
movie the last part of the movie was
actually pretty exciting it was cool
seen her in boot camp and it wasn't
actually as shitty as I thought it was
gonna be here comes the baton switch
guys I know you guys were expecting me
to rip into this movie but here it comes
the tanker scene in Metal Gear Solid 2
is done here comes your riding
I thought divergent was actually a good
time no alcohol required holy [ __ ] I
just gave this movie a positive review
I'm you shocked I know it house hell
yeah thanks dick
oh I'm sorry I didn't know where's the
divergent have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you